hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown states across
the nation are easing their coronavirus
restrictions as the US starts to reopen
are Americans going about it the right
way
special pathogens expert dr. Saira Medad
joins host Lisa Brady to share what
advice she would give governors and
local leaders and whether she would feel
safe getting a haircut
Dyanne aberrant one of the earliest
covin 19 patients in New York sits down
with host Dave Anthony to discuss how
she overcame the virus and her effort to
encourage other survivors to donate
their plasma for medical research plus
commentary from mark Penton former
Clinton pollster and Managing Partner of
the Stagg well group the Fox News
rundown is a Daily News podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player by going to
FoxNews podcast.com i'm stuart varney
i'm harris faulkner I'm Chris Wallace
and this is the Fox News rundown
Wednesday May 6 2020
I'm Lisa Brady keep the masks at the
ready yes America is beginning to reopen
but for now the new normal needs a lot
of precautions this isn't something that
we're gonna open up and that's a done
deal I'm Koga 19 is gone I'm Dave
Anthony she was one of the early corona
patients in New York now Diana Barrett
is reaching out to other survivors in
what she terms a call to arms literally
inside the arm of every kovat 19
survivor are the aunt is the antibody
rich plasma that will help lead us to a
cure and I'm mark Penn I've got the
final word on the Fox News rundown
President Trump calls it the next stage
of battle a safe and gradual reopening
of the country from coronavirus
shutdowns but there are many variations
of that and not every state is on board
yet you reopen too soon or you reopen
unintelligently and you can then have an
immediate backlash New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo says the human cost of
reopening must be considered the
president argues the shutdowns also have
a human cost we can't keep our country
close for the next five years you know
you can say that might be a recurrence
and there there might be and you know
most doctors or some doctors say that it
will happen and it'll be a flame and
we're going to put the flame out he's
getting ready to wind down the original
coronavirus task force as part of
shifting the focus to safety and opening
he's also downplaying a leaked FEMA memo
about possible scenarios with much
higher numbers of deaths in the u.s. if
social distancing is relaxed prematurely
for example the president speaking to
reporters Tuesday before visiting a
Honeywell plant that makes n95 masks in
Arizona his first public event out of
Washington in weeks johns hopkins later
released a statement emphasizing that
the leaked information was not intended
to be used as forecasts reassurance for
Americans trying to decide if they're
ready to test the waters beyond the
grocery store one of the things you know
is important to understand and I think
everybody seeing this play out is that
Kovan 19 is impacting various localities
in different ways dr. Saira Medad is
senior director of the New York City
Health Systems special pathogens program
recently featured on the Netflix donkey
series pandemics and this also holds
true not just at the state level but
also within the state so even at the
local level so clover 19 the burden of
the disease is more significant in
certain pockets of a state than others
and so it can't be that were opening up
the entire state we really have to look
at what's happening at the local level
and make those decisions so if you are
having a very high
number of new infections or you already
have a very high number of existing
infections and you're waiting for that
to continue to go down then it's not a
good idea to open up or you know start
lifting any social distancing measures
and so all of these the citizens really
need to be made first based on data and
metrics and then looking at some of the
trigger points in terms of a safe
reopening is there something additional
you would be recommending you know that
isn't already being done so you know
everybody we need to strike a balance
between life and livelihood right and so
we obviously want to make sure we're
protecting life we want to reduce
morbidity and mortality but at the same
time we want to make sure you know these
are people's livelihoods I don't mind as
the the economy that we want to get
started which is also extremely
important so in order for us to any
location to get started you want to make
sure you have at least some of the basic
foundations in place so this includes
make first making sure you have health
care capacity so you've been hearing
during the peak of you know Cova 19 here
particularly in the state of New York
there was a rush on hospital resources a
significant amount of shortages
whereas in terms of staffing interpreted
in terms of supplies we certainly don't
want to go back to that that same state
so you want to make sure that health
care facilities first have capacity and
the resources they need so when you're
opening up and lifting these social
distancing measures you're obviously
going to have new cases you just need to
make sure that you can care for these
new cases safely and effectively the
second is not just only having health
care capacity but also making sure that
you have diagnostic capabilities so
anybody that needs to get tested should
be able to get tested and then really
the third is making sure that people all
you know also understand that this isn't
something that we're gonna open up and
it's a done deal
and Cova 19 is gone we're opening up in
the backdrop of a highly you know
transmissible virus and so the virus is
still out there it's going to continue
to do what it does best which is in fact
people and so if we're giving chances of
people to get together that's increasing
the chances of spreading the virus and
and creating new chains of transmission
so people need to understand they need
to continue on you
with these everyday measures we want to
make sure people continue wearing a mask
if they're gonna be in six feet and the
individual the doing is everyday
practices like washing their hands and
then really on top of that really
understanding that if cases do continue
to rise then you will probably see
another shelter in place so this is this
is gonna be almost a you know a
stop-and-go approach because right now
you know not in terms of treatment there
there is nothing really available right
now I did want to ask you about testing
specifically because an awful lot is
riding on testing it seems to be the
basis for a lot of decisions that are
made by health officials and elected
officials but even two months into this
not all tests are created equal right I
mean how concerned are you that maybe
some of the tests are still not as
accurate as others first there are two
different buckets of tests
first there's the antigen test and the
antigen jeff's test is looking for if
you have if you have the virus currently
and if you're infected the other type of
test is a serology tests and the
serology tests looks to see if you've
recovered and if you bought if your body
has produced antibodies for example from
Kovan 19 so it doesn't look to see if
you are currently infected like the
antigen test it looks to see if you've
recovered so those different types of
tests and certainly as you mentioned you
know no two tests are created this name
and that's very when we talk about the
serology testing because that's kind of
like the the big buzzword right now is
you know serology testing and getting
tested for antibodies there are over a
hundred different types of tests for
serology in the United States and a very
small handful you know less than five
are actually you know gone through that
FDA process and have kind that you know
that seal of you know approval in the
sense that you know it's it's it's
effective and it's specific and it gives
at least you know confidence in the
results that it has so there is a lot of
tests out there that are probably
providing false positives and that's
like that's very worrisome because this
is dealing with people's lives as we
want to make sure that these tests are
safe and effective and they actually do
what they're intended they're intended
purposes part of the reason I asked that
question is because my brother-in-law
ended up in the hospital with a case of
double pneumonia and he had been exposed
to cope at 19 at work and he had a test
before he ended up in the hospital and
he was still waiting for those results
when he ended up in the hospital the
hospital did their own rapid tests that
came out negative
later when he got out of the hospital he
got the first round of results back and
those were also negative so he tested
negative for kovat 19 twice but then he
went and had the antibody test and that
came back positive yeah that's very you
know that's very concerning but I think
that also there's a couple of different
factors that can influence the results
of a test at first it could be the test
itself and how effective it is and the
confidence in terms of the results that
you know it it displays if you will but
the other is also the individual that's
getting tested themselves so it also
depends on was there enough sample size
to actually produce a valid result the
second is how far along were you you
know in your infectious face if you will
so in the incubation phase so you know
as we know is 14-day incubation period
you know what we've seen was a lot of
viruses and this is not just unique took
over 19 is that sometimes early on you
don't have enough let's just say virus
in your body for it has to be able to
detect it and so if you test on day one
you might be negative but if you test
them on day three they may be positive
let me give you a couple of real-world
examples to try to sort of guide people
a little bit let's say your town is
partially reopened and you're allowed to
go get a haircut
if the stylist and you were both wearing
a mask would you then would you go ahead
and get a haircut would you feel safe
doing it if I'm in the if I first if I
you know compromised if I and in the
high-risk group then I would not want to
leave my home because you know the
chances of me having a worse or outcome
obviously is very high that's also not
to say that a young individual is
invincible we are seeing a lot of cases
that even individuals younger than 50 60
or
we'll do have you know critical or
severe outcome and so no one should feel
as if they're invincible but especially
if you're in a high-risk group you
should not go out at all you know but if
you feel as if you need to go out I
think people really need to see what is
something that that is essential but if
they're going to get a haircut you know
you know you want to make sure you're
doing some of these protective measures
so certainly at least wear you know a
facemask both you know individuals and
then limiting contact as much as
possible so you know if they're only
touching your hair making sure that
you're washing your hands afterwards
you're not touching your mucous
membranes and and kind of go on from
there not touching those high touch
surfaces I think it's just it's a way we
have to figure out a way to make sure
that we are able to continue to socially
distance ourselves and making sure that
we are taking the protective measures as
much as possible during the backdrop of
koban 19 in perpetuity until we have a
vaccine or therapeutic available that
would be able to start you know seeing
an impact on the overall community
one last question because I did I was
fortunate enough to speak with you in
late February and a lots changed in the
past couple of months to say the least
has this outbreak progressed kind of the
way you would have expected it to
progress and are you optimistic at this
point about you know what's been done
and where we are it certainly has not
progressed the way that I would have
imagined and the reason for that is
first knowing basic about virology and
knowing how special especially
respiratory viruses you know interact
had we been able to implement a number
of these public health measures earlier
on we wouldn't have been in the same
position that we're in today and so it's
one of those things where you were you
know for me I think I was hopeful or
optimistic they hopeful that we would
have done a lot of these measures sooner
so we would have seen less of an impact
of this respiratory virus that we're
seeing now that obviously was not the
case and so now we're dealing with a
very high number of cases throughout the
United States not
here in the state of New York and so now
we have to make sure that we are
following the data we're following the
metrics and we're changing our public
health strategies as needed so earlier
on you know we were trying to not even
contain the virus we were mitigating the
virus this is why we had social
distancing in place because I was their
biggest weapon you know we know that we
weren't able to do the contact tracing
because there's just too many cases now
the the public health strategy is
starting to shift and now what we want
to do is do you know case based
intervention and what this means is that
now that cases are not coming down we
want to be able to identify these cases
isolate them do that contact tracing and
then quarantine those contacts and so
some of the strategies are now starting
to shift and we still want to make sure
that that is happening and I think from
my standpoint I was hopeful that that
would have happened at the get-go but
the obviously was not the case because
there was too many cases to deal with
but now that will hopefully in certain
parts of the United States where the
cases are starting to dip down we're
able to do some of these case based
interventions now dr. Saira Medad
special pathogens expert thanks so much
for coming back on the rundown thanks
for having me
[Music]
this is Mart pen with your fox news
commentary coming up she got sick in
early March
just as the corona virus outbreak was
picking up steam in New York I got a
call late this afternoon that I did
indeed test positive for covered 19
that's from a blog Diana baron started
while she was isolated at home feeling
nauseous her throat sore and massive
unrelenting headache I've been taking
tylenol pretty constantly but one thing
she said after she tested positive
stands out i've actually relieved did at
this point because if i'm gonna go
through all this I might as well have
some immunity at the end I guess it's
unclear if she or anyone who had the
virus is immune from getting it again
but she started a movement
Diana baron founded survivor core to
band with others who beat the virus to
donate plasma from their blood
containing antibodies helping other
patients and researchers I never in a
million years thought that I would be
the first one in my area to be diagnosed
she had been vigilant trying not to get
the virus you know as much as I'm not a
germaphobe I am a bit of a news junkie
and so I had been watching the news
coming out of China and out of then out
of Italy and I really saw that this was
coming our way and so for weeks prior to
getting sick you know before anyone was
really paying attention I was making my
children every day when they got home
from school stripped off all their
clothes everything went in the hot wash
they had to shower immediately we had
cancelled all you know routine medical
appointments and we're being generally
quite cautious how did you end up
getting the virus so I was at a meeting
on Monday March 9th where it turns out
that I later found out several of the
people who were at that meeting had been
at a conference in the previous days in
very early March in the city at the
Sheridan hotel where there had been an
outbreak sort of one of these Biogen
type vortexes of contagion and so you
know no one went into the meeting with
you know intentionally knowing at that
point
they weren't symptomatic but everyone at
the meeting did get infected there were
only eight of us which is under the ten
recommended just important to keep in
mind and there are people who I had only
met a couple of times before so wasn't
social there was no sharing of food or
anything else but everyone did contract
it and one person has since died of it
so every yeah everybody at that meeting
got the virus exactly and it was nobody
was sitting particularly close to one
another you know as I said it wasn't
social you know it but that's how
contagious this is oh my goodness and so
then you go home and and how long before
you start feeling sick so that was on
the evening of the ninth I woke up on
the morning of Friday the 13th and you
can read into that what you want and not
a particularly suspicious person before
but maybe now I should be and there was
nothing subtle about it I had blisters
in the back of my throat I had a hundred
and at least 102 fever and I had a
respiratory infection I felt like I had
an anvil on my chest and the first thing
I did and I thank goodness for this
every day is within 15 minutes of waking
up with those symptoms I grabbed my
laptop and a couple of other things and
I went into my bedroom and I stayed in
self isolation other than leaving to go
get tested I didn't leave the four
corners of my bedroom for 18 days which
brings us back to Diana's blog including
a video diary I'm still pretty tired I'm
on day seven of being in complete self
isolation in my bedroom missed my kids
[Music]
and I haven't really been able to eat in
a week see you tomorrow and while she
was alone she was busy going back to the
days before she was sick retracing her
steps reaching out to everyone she might
have had contact with to alert them they
could be at risk I think that there's an
overriding civic duty to make sure that
if you are infected that the infection
stops at you so that you're not
responsible for the continued spread how
does it test it in the end because it
wasn't easy to get tested back with not
easy to get tested at all in fact I ran
into this you know we'll sort of
catch-22 situation where they refused to
test me because I couldn't prove ten
minutes of sustained close exposure to
an individual who had tested positive
but at that point nobody was being
tested and those who had been tested
weren't revealing their identity so it
was an impossibility I ended up writing
a put a letter to my you know very local
representatives on you know Town Council
up to County Executive and I then posted
that letter on Facebook that night I was
so frustrated because I couldn't report
to them to my kids school districts this
was back in you know schools were still
open businesses were still open social
distancing was not even a term that had
entered our collective vocabulary at
that yes it's really all changed so fast
it's amazing yeah it has and so that
that post ended up being shared
overnight thousands of times which was
you know just crazy to watch and it
reached my congressman who Tom Suozzi
who represents the third District here
in New York and he intervened to
personally get me tested which was you
know a success for me but not a scalable
solution by any means for all of the
other people who were to follow who were
in the same situation
right right right so did anybody in your
family you you said you're isolated in
your bedroom for for nearly three weeks
did anybody and your family get it other
than you they did
um my my cup my husband caught it from
me he had a much more mild case and I
believe both of my children also had it
but neither of them got tested so how
did you go from someone in isolation who
you were certainly vocal about your case
and getting tested and trying to reach
out to others but how did you get from
being a patient to getting involved the
way you are and founding survivor core
how did that happen I know had this sort
of aha moment of realizing that I was
gonna be one of the first people
diagnosed I could um you know Paul went
well I'd be one of the first survivors
and with that came with the
responsibility but also an incredible
opportunity and I remember just enough
back of my 10th grade biology I remember
I have no science background no public
health background but I remember just
enough of my 10th grade biology to
realize that I would come out with
antibodies and those antibodies could
potentially provide immunity and if we
could gather together you know I might
have an individual in this sort of
individual superpower then in my blood
if I you know at the end of this virus
but there were going to be thousands to
come after me and if we could mobilize
as a massive movement that we could have
incredible power and so what what
survivor core really has done is we have
issued a call to arms literally arms
because inside the arm of every coated
19 survivor are the aunt is the antibody
rich plasma that will help lead us to a
cure and so we are mobilizing an army of
volunteers to go out to donate their
plasma to donate their blood to
participate in every research trial
program that is going on from the
scientific medical and academic
community Diana also posted video
ah forgetting that corona test at an
urgent care facility in Port Washington
on Long Island outside New York City now
she posts when she donates the plasma
from her blood helping start a clinical
trial at Columbia University or now
there is a 6,000 person waiting list to
help other corona patients the use of
convalescent plasma is being you know
it's been around for over a hundred
years the Nobel Prize was won in 1901
for its use against diphtheria and it
was used more recently with h1n1 with
SARS with Ebola it's sort of it's a
time-honored method but it's you know
it's it's not the final stop it this is
a stopgap effort to help save lives
until we have a vaccine alright you were
patient number one in the trial that
Columbia is doing how how what happened
you you donated your blood and it went
where so the icing on the cake was
finding out that I am blood type a B+
which for plasma matches means that I'm
a universal donor which is only about 4%
of the population and so as my doctor
said my plasma is like liquid gold
because to those patients who have the
rarer blood types who are harder to
match so I once I got the clearance from
Columbia I went to the New York Blood
Center which is now actually an official
partner with a survivor Corps as is the
American Association of blood banks and
various other blood centers around the
country and right now their wolves are
you can donate every 7 days with a
maximum of 8 times in 12 weeks so I've
now donated 4 times I have a standing
weekly appointment I go every Wednesday
and my first donation went back to
Columbia to be used for research so
right now they just got approval and
they their study has started to really
figure out the how effective
convalescent plasma is
and really trying to figure out when
it's best used right now it's only been
used on a compassionate care basis so
for people who are critically ill if
there's a end-of-life but the probably
the greater potential will be for it to
be used earlier in the in the viral
cycle and even creating a more
concentrated refined version of it
called type immune globulin which could
even potentially be used to as a shot to
give to frontline workers who are going
to be exposed to a high viral load and
we're seeing you know the more virus you
are exposed to it looks like the sicker
you get so if we can inoculate those
individuals with a boost of antibodies
it could really protect them in the long
run you know it really has the direct
potential to save you know as they say
three to four lives per donation giving
blood is something a lot of us are
familiar with but Diana says donating
plasma is different and you don't get
lightheaded afterward and need to
recover the they take the blood out with
the single needle and there's this
futuristic machine sitting next to you
and that has a centrifuge in it that
literally separates out the golden
liquid plasma from the blood the red and
white blood cells the red stuff that
we're used to thinking of as Bluff they
separate out the plasma and then they
put the blood right back into you so
there's really there's no recovery at
all I've driven myself back and forth to
each appointment and the last couple of
times I forgot to even pick up the you
know the Oreos and shoes that they offer
you on the way out you know people on
Survivor core are posting their donation
selfies as a badge of honor and you can
see on every single person just an
ear-to-ear grin it is truly one of the
most gratifying experiences I've ever
experienced and I look I don't mean this
to offend my family but I would put it
along the lines of getting married and
having children how many
in a lifetime do you have to save a
single life let alone multiple lives in
a single half-hour painless procedure
well that is incredible and you can read
all about it at survivor Corps com die
in aberrant is the founder a coronavirus
survivor and Diana thanks very much for
joining us thank you so much
[Music]
from the Fox News podcasts Network
download and listen to everyone talks to
Liz Fox businesses liz claman talks with
entrepreneurs and executives about
inspiring and motivational stories
subscribe and listen now by going to fox
news podcasts calm Raiden review the fox
news rundown on Apple podcasts or
wherever you listen it's time for your
fox news commentary mark heaven what's
on your mind
had the Department of Justice released
the newly disclosed documents related to
General Michael Flynn three years ago
instead of fired FBI director James
Comey improperly leaking his quote memos
unquote on President Trump
there definitely would have been a
special counsel only it would have been
investigating the FBI for gross abuse of
power not the Trump administration the
new documents are in effect The Smoking
Gun proving that a cabal at the FBI
acted above the law and with extreme
political bias targeting people for
prosecution
rather than investigating crimes Michael
Flynn was targeted for investigations
not on the basis of any evidence but
simply because he had contacts with the
Russian government something that our
hope would be true of any incoming
national security adviser the new
documents reveal that despite a thorough
investigation of Flynn there was no
evidence suggesting he was a Russian
agent one FBI memo just released
recommended the closing of the
investigation of Flynn On January 4 2017
because FBI agents found quote no
derogatory information in quote but then
FBI agent Peter struck intervene with
the idea that the never-used Logan Act
could be invoked against Flynn all this
led to a meeting at the highest levels
of the FBI which included the director
and the FBI's head of
counterintelligence who took copious
notes it is in these notes that he
reflected the disgust
that took place of our Flynn writing
truth slash admission or to get him to
lie so that we can prosecute or get him
fired end quote
no construct constitutional protections
were afforded Flynn who was even advised
by the FBI not to bring a lawyer when he
was questioned by agents let's be candid
Flynn had been cleared of being a
Russian agent On January 4th 2017 there
never was any evidence he should have
been investigated in the first place yet
now because the investigation had not
been officially closed FBI officials
cooked up a plan to try to create a
crime that did not exist they unmasked
the private conversations of Flynn with
the Russian ambassador that contained
nothing illegal so that the only chance
to quote get Flynn was by sending a
perjury trap why were they so desperate
to get Flynn fired or prosecuted when
there was no evidence whatsoever that he
committed a crime former federal
prosecutor Andrew McCarthy suggests they
needed to get him out of the way of
their investigation I think it is more
likely that they simply wanted to get
their targets at all costs and sustained
their investigation to bring down the
administration it's all coming out now
but it's way too late
Attorney General William Barr seems to
see this all very clearly but the time
to act with tough indictments is truly
now with the release of these explosive
documents the actions in the Flynn case
provide the link between the struck page
texts about quote insurance policies
against Trump's elections and actions
that were indefensible on every level
they show how two of them acted in
concert to extend their political
prejudices to the department's actions
against people who are no way colluding
with Russia it did not matter to these
FBI officials
who acted as though they were above the
law they would get their targets and
drag the country through years of a
meritless investigation and a false
political debate I am mark Patton
you've been listening to the FoxNews
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com love fox news
click the subscribe button to get more
of the news and opinion you trust and
click the FoxNews rundown playlist for
the latest episodes